[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 76
it is pandemonium here we have gone
out into portland to see how things have
changed overnight and it has caused
chaos but
we are here with you to discuss what is
going on and
its relevance to uh you know the future
if there is one
indeed today we are going to talk some
about about portland about our hometown
which we still love
and um and we know that most of the
people living here love it too
and therefore we have to wonder over and
over again why what is happening is
being allowed to happen so we're going
to talk something some about what's
happening
unfortunately we did not have the time
to get all of our pictures and video
totally organized
this is not right um but we're gonna
show some
of those to you and for those of you
listening only um we'll describe what
we're showing
uh then we are going to uh talk about
some of the numbers
in stories from this week we got the
number three the number 90
the number 13 and the number 2.5 billion
i'm concerned
about the number 13. 2.5 billion i can
handle but 13's always been rough
no 2.5 billion is a familiar kind of
cozy feeling number
not to me really to me no it's sort of i
think i think you're going to feel
differently once you hear
why 2.5 billion is in the news no no but
kinesthetically speaking it's sort of a
color of mauve i've never liked
kinesthetically yes really kinesthetic
that's not the term what's the term
i don't know what you're trying to say
oh synthetic synesthetic that's what i
meant yes
synesthetically i would say i don't have
synesthesia but if i did it would be a
color of mom that i just uh
i i can't tolerate well this is a
conversation for another time but as you
know
i have long thought that we all um start
out with
some degree of synesthesia that we are
sort of part of what childhood is is
learning
how to separate our senses and catalog
them as as separate entities
um sometimes um to a detriment
and also that
there is persistent synesthesia that can
come out in particular situations
um and in fact i think i wrote about
that a little bit in the
in the essay i wrote about having been
mugged at knifepoint in quito
right yes you did okay anyway
um then we're going to talk about a
lizard that isn't a lizard and coyotes
when is a lizard not a lizard that's
such an
an odd thing to to happen so i'm looking
forward to that we're going to find out
so first first announcements
announcements yes announcements that's
traditional
yeah uh no ads today um and
but at my patreon right now the 48-hour
window is open to ask
questions uh for the two-hour private uh
q a that we do every month on the last
sunday of the month at 11 a.m pacific so
if you have been thinking about perhaps
doing that now is a
a good moment to join and then all the
rest of the things are generally true if
you're enjoying this subscribe
like all of that definitely like
definitely like
um all right all right should we um
should we talk portland is gorgeous
especially this week
oh my goodness i think anyone in the
pacific northwest i suspect right now is
having this
just amazing weather unseasonable um
warm not into hot really blue skies
the trees are beginning to leaf out you
know many of the trees the magnolias and
cherries are still in full bloom
the birds are in mating season so
there's a lot of song going on
um it is just a stunning stunning moment
uh in portland and actually an unusual
one because
the leaves are not yet out the flowers
are in bloom and the weather is so
clear we're not dealing with our our
typical coolish
drizzly weather that we would ordinarily
so right well but
no in the summer we usually get this
kind of weather but
the plants are in a different phase and
the birds are in a different phase
so um this is like um august weather
uh with april ecology and it's kind of
amazing
it really is um uh so it's you know it's
it's bringing out
um well let's bring out the coyotes
which we'll talk we talked about last
week
and we'll talk about the end of the hour
here and it's um bringing how we have
begun to um attract
stellar's jays just just glorious and um
it's brought out the writers
yes right out to the streets it's a very
hospitable weather condition and uh
absolutely what else are you going to do
all the festivals are shut down sure
rioting is what's happening yeah yeah so
let's talk a little bit about it um let
us to be honest
it's a little unclear exactly what the
riots in portland are about because
there's a national riot phenomenon
that has seen an uptick as a result uh
ostensibly of a couple of shootings in
various places including chicago
and we also had a shooting here in
portland yesterday about which there's
not
a lot of information and i'm cautious
because early reports are always wrong
and these aren't
um early reports exactly but still there
the
full information isn't out but it sounds
like uh
a white guy seemingly mentally unstable
waving a firearm in a park was shot and
killed
by police and so the pattern that we
have increasingly seen
is that any shooting at all by police
is taken to be a validation of the model
in which the police are simply out of
control and
shooting people willy-nilly and when
race can be invoked it is and when it
can't it's
quietly sidelined and the fact is it's
completely tautological framework
because
the fact is there are a lot of police
and frankly there are a lot of citizens
and there's a lot of crime and there's
uh going to be there are going to be
shootings that
are valid there are going to be
shootings that are errors there is no
way you could do policing that would be
perfect
in this regard and so if what you do is
simply take every time
somebody is shot by police as evidence
that the police are out of control
then you will just have an excuse to
riot uh you know on the regular
well and at some level it's a rejection
of the aphorism that the perfect is the
enemy of the good
right so the perfect is the enemy of the
good we we can
we all of us should be able to recognize
that in a complex system we will not
achieve perfection
um that humans are fallible humans will
commit crime
and um and therefore we need a police
force and not only are
humans imperfect but police are
imperfect and in any demographic be they
police or right-handers or
bolivians or you know short people or
whatever it is
they're going to be some people who are
great and some people who are not um and
that will be true for police as well
um but the idea that if they can't be
perfect if they cannot get the numbers
of errors to zero then we need to get
rid of them entirely
is um yeah gosh we just keep on coming
back here and you know i think we've
been avoiding it more and more because
how often can you say the same thing
right obviously this clearly makes no
sense
it is logic done by people who have no
capacity for logic apparently
or it's just an excuse either way right
um but it's not even that
the errors have to be zero right getting
the errors to zero can't be done
right you you would have to have such a
draconian system
in which no crime could be committed in
which the police would have to
show up that no one would want to live
in it i still i don't think it's
possible
i don't care how draconian you go you
can't you can't get it to zero
i mean you could lock everybody in
solitary confinement and keep them away
from every place in which crime could
conceivably
happen or something but um my point is
my point is there is no livable life
that does not
involve errors however this also isn't
about errors
right we leap to the stage of having
riots
long before anybody knows if the police
made a mistake right and if they had
that's not an invalidation of the
concept of policing
it is not a justification for rioting
there's some level of error you would
expect
but the fact that there doesn't even
need to be an error really tells the
tale
yes not only will no errors be tolerated
at
all zero tolerance for error but also
zero tolerance for force
in response to force like zero
zero tolerance for for state-sponsored
force
in response to street-level force and
violence and looting and rioting and all
of these things
right and obviously people who have the
capacity to think
know that what you're really trying to
opt to do is to minimize
harm right so there will be some harm
done by the police there will be some
harm done by criminals and what you
would like is a system
that overall minimizes harm which does
not mean brings it to zero that is a
utopian
and inconceivable uh outcome but
the fact is there is no every
single instance of anything newsworthy
is taken as
evidence of what the writers imagined
that they already knew
or as i said before or it's simply an
excuse
so we began now we got we got local
chaos but it's not of the
protesting or rioting variety nor is it
another cat quake
um we began to hear inklings just online
last night there was something going on
in portland and then
a good friend of our producer are now 17
happy birthday last week zachary 17 year
old son
um happened to have been coming home
from the coast last night stopped
downtown
and called zach and said hey the apple
store appears to be on fire in downtown
portland
um so um we have a few of the videos
of that that that young man took the
friend of
of our son who i'm not gonna name
because we didn't ask if we could
yep um and um and then the three of us
brett zach and i actually went downtown
this morning
um and to assess what we were seeing
to assess what had actually happened and
uh and you know found some things a
little bit different than what you're
expecting
and uh and a lot of things that were
pretty reflective of what we've been
told we would see so we're going to show
you some of that as well
so zach would you like to show some of
your friends
video
see fire so again this is from last
night this is from just after midnight
on would be april 17th yep
in portland
so if we go uh is there sound zach
okay so uh if i can be heard over this
just describing to people who are
merely listening um we've just got you
know street view
shots of here's a dumpster that
is smoldering closed it's probably on
fire we don't we can't see that for sure
we saw that dumpster this morning it was
definitely
i know we're going we're getting there
okay we're talking about last night
um and then there was at least one more
zach unless i missed it
okay i thought there was an i thought
there was one showing the one actually
at
the dumpster actually outside of the
apple store on fire
okay um so uh
i can't we're so we're now looking at a
white screen
um okay okay
um so uh this looks um
like a stepping up of the same sorts of
riots that we were seeing
uh last summer do we want to look at
some other pictures absolutely um
i thought maybe we'd start um with uh
signs the first thing on my list zach
that i sent you
um
no because they're not in the right
order um
okay why don't you just lead zach i mean
prep all right so
why don't you flip forward here
all right so traditional sentiments all
cops are best
hold on no so i really don't want to
show these until the end so that one
there
that one and the next one for which
there was a composite shot that i
had wanted to be the one we were showing
here is all one street and so we have
store closing everything must go with an
entirely borrowed up street and then if
you
go back um to the last one you see right
next door
um anarchy sign an a-cap all caps are
about
all cops or bastards and several other
things which are visible in the in the
larger photograph but
um not here so um i want to come back to
my other photos but not
now because i want to show them at the
end of what you want to show
okay so zach do you want to put up the
other set of photos
all right so so here this is
exactly adjacent to the apple store
and you see something that has become
very common here
in portland downtown so you've had
windows busted up
they are they have plywood or osb
put over them and then these spontaneous
murals go up
and the murals are of various different
kinds some of them are accusations
some of them are designed to portray the
uh the protesters as
uh peace loving and creative so
presumably we're gonna show a bunch of
these murals like
there are a lot right a lot of the lots
of good numbers but
many of them have high production values
yeah like actually beautiful street art
that
you know if if if there was a place to
put it that wasn't about having smashed
windows and so put wood up in its place
um i think that there could could
legitimately be a place for
this sort of art in a functioning city
yeah although i would say
you know you have talented people but
the the fact that
somebody is able to put up something
colorful and
load whatever payload into it they wish
and that this somehow speaks for the
people of portland is absolutely
appalling so
even though some of the murals may say
things
that one could resonate with a lot of
them really don't
and you know either you need some sort
of authority to decide what sentiments
can be represented even if you were
going to have some place where
street art could uh could be put up by
by citizens and then the problem is all
right who decides what sentiment
is going to go where yeah so this one
you can't see the third
frame of this mural what it says and
it's also hard to read
but what it how it reads if you're
looking straight on is if my heart stops
turning will the world do the same
and this strikes me as like okay hearts
don't turn
forget the you know basic biological
innumeracy or whatever it is
um no worries on that front but um
i i feel like the
the initiative behind the sentiment is a
desire
to have to know that if someone if their
heart stops beating
the whole world will stop right and uh
it reveals this level of narcissism
uh absent
any apparent desire to fix things or to
make things right
it is entirely about me in the moment
and destruction right and this actually
goes to
the the heart of the misunderstanding
here
which is in some sense the puzzle is
about
whatever we are continuing into the
future
and the attack on these structures
makes it very likely that this system
and all those who depend on it will not
meaningfully continue into the future we
will be subjugated by someone else or
will be overrun by some civilization
that didn't lose its mind
and so watching people who conflate
their own well-being who
basically demand that the world stop if
they do
is preposterous a reasonable person
understands that you are
rooting for your people whoever they are
irrespective of whether you're present
if you died tomorrow do you stop
caring about the people that you love no
you're rooting for them and
suddenly they're hobbled by the fact
that they don't have your
insight or help in uh in
dealing with the challenges of life but
it doesn't change your
sense about whether or not you know
things matter things matter whether or
not you're there
and so they've lost they've lost sight
of this completely
so where i was hoping to go to first
though was just you know
was the apple store on fire did the
apple store burned to the ground
um i know you have some pictures of that
i'd like us to show those to
to respond to you know just social media
at the moment is
as usual after these things happen
completely polarized
um and um and
we were just there we actually talked to
one of the workers who was working on
cleaning up the
so zach can you show uh one of the
pictures from the um
yeah there you go it's a little dark
unfortunately but let's describe it so
we're looking at the same mural that you
were just looking at up close
there's a dumpster out in front that has
clearly been burned we can show you that
up close in a second
and then to the right there you see
barricades
which are around the apple store
which was being renovated and by the
dumpster
is the awning that they apparently set
fire like the dumpster is under the
awning they set fire to that
the awning's gone the tree is burned and
the dumpster was apparently inside the
uh
um in inside the apple store compound
as were the bathrooms um that were there
for the workers to
fix the repairs from the previous riots
right and the bathrooms got burned to
the ground
so um so anyway yes the apple compound
did burn the building did not burn to
the ground nor is it
very conceivable that it could given
what it's built out of but nonetheless
there apple was targeted here yeah
and a lot of damage was done now you
have a picture of
the placard that apple's got on the
outside i don't have it
ready i took it but i didn't capture it
but uh could you show the mural
on the apple store
so i want to describe something here so
this mural is no longer on the apple
store but it is worth understanding
uh its history in order to understand
uh or to put in context the events of
last night
so the apple store i believe was being
renovated for its own reasons um
and was open for one day post-renovation
and then it was shut down by covid in
the aftermath of being shut down by
kovid
it was uh attacked during riots
windows were broken people broke in and
then
apple decided to put up basically a
black
wall um all around a plywood
wall so and um then
on that wall a local artist
spontaneously
put up a mural focused on george floyd
and the famous line i can't breathe
and apple decided to leave the mural in
place many other artists
then contributed to the mural and
ultimately
the mural was donated by apple
to don't shoot pdx which is a local
uh police watch group now
currently on the outer fence of the
apple compound there is a sign heather
you have it you want to read it
yeah i really i wanted i thought we were
going to show this yes please
so it reads apple stands with you in the
fight for racial and social justice
black lives matter the community it's
not in those pictures zach i just sent
it to you
um the community artwork has been
entrusted to don't shoot portland in
support of their mission for social
change
don't shoot portland a local black-led
human rights non-profit organization
will incorporate the artwork
as part of their children's art and
social justice council programming
for more information visit pdx.org
and there's another one um that um i was
not the one who photographed it
um that's even more sort of it's it's
again
one of these don't hurt me walls and so
apple not only is putting money to
in the other one they indicate they're
sending that they're putting money
towards
these causes and um and this is the
response
right so i i want to um
hone that to a slightly sharper point
yeah
apple this is your fault you did this to
us
you caused this riot now it may be that
it would have happened without your help
but it certainly did happen
with your help and the fact that you are
pretending
that uh people attacking your store and
you having to put up plywood and that
creating an opportunity for a local
artist to expect
express a sentiment that i don't think
represents us universally
and then you treat this as something
that has to be honored
is creating the problem and basically we
have
you know runaway woke capital and woke
capital
has you know the back end the business
end where it does whatever it does
financially speaking and it has the
front end
where it coddles this kind of sentiment
in public and
god damn it the problem with the don't
hurt me walls
is that what don't hurt me really means
is go hurt somebody else so apple
not only did you have this coming
because you set us up for it
but the rest of us who did not have it
coming got it too as a result of your
activity yeah and and
this sort of statement by the
corporations
um and and small businesses but you know
the small businesses have
more to lose have a higher fraction of
their livelihood to lose
um is creating the sense
among people that this is the majority
sentiment that most portlanders are
behind this
right and in fact we were standing there
on the corner um
of the apple store downtown this morning
and um
there were a number of people there
looking
what had happened and um sort of you
know some of us were talking
and a guy drove by and what he said
through his open window was
the most the vast majority of people in
portland approve of this
and he was you know he was pissed and
and you know a lot of us are pissed
legitimately
um but he said this and then he drove
off his light turned green he wasn't
running away or anything
but i wanted to say to him i don't i'm
sure that's not true
i am put put anyone
almost anyone from portland on this
corner and look at what's happening
and look at what has happened and
recognize that anyone who's tried to
walk around downtown in the last year
um in the last 11 months 10 months now
and ask them if they approve of this and
mostly they're going to say no that
doesn't mean that most portlanders
understand the various the various
concerns
and reasons that it's happening but the
fact that downtown has become
a disaster area in which
this could happen any day that it's nice
out expect that there may be
at the best vandals running around and
that it's increasingly difficult
to find police who can do their jobs in
part because they've been massively
defunded
in part because many of them have left
because their jobs have become
worse than thankless and in parts
because they've had their hands tied by
the
the city leadership yes in fact uh
we have many different entities playing
a role that creates the exact conditions
that are going to lead to this
and um zach can you show the uh
graffiti in the stairway
yep you you briefly passed through it
by the way we yeah um
you did
okay here it is so this is just a piece
of graffiti this is now commonplace in
portland what it says
is kill a cop for fun and it has
a picture of a smiley face underneath
um it is not uncommon to see sentiments
like this
the idea that police are deserving of
being
murdered we also see a graffiti like
this about andy no
a journalist not recently but i believe
a journalist was actually
assaulted last night if i understood
what i saw on twitter correctly a
portland journalist
but in any case you have people
telling you what they're actually about
right this protest if you were
protesting something important and
somebody else in your protest was saying
kill cops for fun
then you would distance yourself so that
your important point
wasn't lost in an obviously crazy point
um and yet that does not happen we have
the mixture of all of these
things together and they result in
people being able
to find what they want those who want to
see these
riots sympathetically can find
sentiments that they resonate with
and those who want to see the whole
picture find chaos because it's an
incoherent
set of statements and frankly anarchism
is so much at the root of this
anarchists who
uh in the aftermath of you know after
protesting and claiming that this was
all driven by
donald trump as soon as joe biden won
we saw them attack the democratic
headquarters and proclaim
we are ungovernable and the answer is
look you are ungovernable
the rest of us are not ungovernable we
wish to be governed well
and you it's not yours to say whether
any of us get good government
right good government is essential if
you don't understand that and you're
going to violate the law
then you need to pay the price and what
we have in this city
is we have corporations
and city government that are coddling
these crazy beliefs we have businesses
that you know at you know are
regularly trying to get vandals to move
on to someone else which of course puts
someone else
in the crosshairs and then we have well
but it's it's not
in the purview of any small business to
uh obliterate the vandals you know
that's that's the government's job
right it's the government's job and the
point is
we in portland who understand that
governance is necessary
are a majority certainly right we're not
all insane and the problem is
it has become hard to say that we need
good governance that we need
policing it needs to be good but yes we
need policing no don't defund don't
abolish
right these things are necessary to a
functional um
society and so what we are now seeing is
what happens
when you try to appease crazy people
who don't understand the basics and you
know we're getting unfortunately
what we collectively ordered and yeah
and it's i mean it's it's
going to get terrible again like i mean
this this is bad enough but it's going
to get terrible again like it was last
summer
in part for the same reasons that it
happened last summer and forget their
cover story forget like oh it's going to
be the
chauvin trial verdict it's going to be
this that you know some you know
that's all cover story yep it's all
cover story
the fact is we have a lot of people
who are dispossessed who have who have
no cannot see a way forward in the world
in which they will be productive
and interested and interesting and
whether or not they
recognize of that um it is a combination
of an economy that is not serving people
and crazy loads of student debt and
credit card debt
and many people have been medicated into
oblivion so they can't even recognize
what their own moods are
and they're on their damn phones all the
time and they're just
stuck in a hellscape
from which they cannot escape and now
the lockdowns continue there are going
to be
seemingly almost no live events through
the northern hemisphere summer
that's two summers in a row with no
outlets
no no festivals no concerts
no ability to get together and have fun
and brawl and all well okay guess what
we're gonna do then
we're gonna do the thing that the health
experts have said
is reflective of the actual pandemic
which is systemic racism
these people aren't about systemic
racism some of them
originally and i mean you've you as as
you revealed in your conversation with
brittany king
and as you revealed in your
conversations with uh jeremy lee quinn
um that you know this is a whole
mishmash of of people
but neither you nor i have said about
what is happening
right now in portland or has been
happening in this last week these are
protests that became riots as we said
about this what was happening all of
last summer right because those were
regular protests and for the most part
we didn't think the protests made a ton
of sense
but they were good faith and some of
them
many of them were actually about you
know real heartfelt sentiment and desire
for real honest good change but reliably
like clockwork every night in portland
they became riots
and this that's happening right now this
isn't doesn't even have a pretense yeah
it's not even pretending to be protest
so to be clear about it two things came
together last summer
right we have a long-standing fringe
anarchist movement
yeah it has been very active in the
pacific northwest for a long time all
the way
uh wto and and long before that yeah um
so what's that like 99 or 2001 one of
those two something something in that
neighborhood
but um it fused with black lives matter
last summer in the george floyd protest
era and so
you know for a while it was sort of
cloaked in this
uh this excuse and now you know the two
things have more or less parted ways
and here what we do now is we just skip
right to the right
without you know any meaningful
explanation i
do want to correct one thing though you
said
that it's going to get worse it doesn't
have to it's going to get worse because
we are going to do the same thing that
leads it to get worse
the thing that apple did which now apple
has
been punished for for coddling this
sentiment
right that thing results in it getting
worse
the uh treating these crimes lightly
uh not arresting people when you do
arrest thing
arrest them setting low bail the fact of
the population creating a bail fund in
which people who
uh vandalize businesses are
then legally supported by the public and
even frankly i have to say
zach could you put up the picture of the
volunteer this morning
i wanted to do something before that
that's not a volunteer neither is that
there we go so this is one of of many
uh volunteers who are cleaning up
the streets of portland this morning as
they do reliably can we actually so i
really wanted to finish with that before
we go into talking about the schools
okay very quickly can we just do one
thing first um
zach you had in the in the pictures that
you were showing that you said were from
me
um something that's a picture that said
united by love can you put that up
um so this was outside this is you know
these are the fancy stories in downtown
portland
and um this i think was a tiffany store
maybe i'm not sure i didn't this
united by love and then the next one
which is right next composition on that
photo
is excellent thank you thank you um
um the next one should have been
okay okay so the pictures that you've
shown you need to find the pictures
of the women's faces um that have been
vandalized
that were right next to that were part
of the tiffany store i don't know if
they're in mine
i have i sent it to you so um i'm going
to describe them for those of you
listening
um there is an array of photographs
there we go
no that's it those are them um
of and this is yeah it's tiffany uh and
it's women
it's it's white women and women of color
and um
right next to this united by love sign
and all of the white women have had
their faces xed out
um except there's one white woman in
profile who
they didn't get i think they just didn't
recognize her as human or something they
their algorithm didn't work
it may be how they understood she
identifies yeah probably so
so um united by love you say so this you
know this elite
brand right like i don't i don't know if
i've ever even been in a tiffany's
um i mostly know of it from the
the hemming someone hemingway who who is
it the film
oh uh hepburn not tammy way audrey
hepburn in breakfast at tiffany's
um but united by love and then we see
that um it's it's only
people with skin of a particular color
and um that
i don't know that reminds me of eras in
which there's been no love uniting
people
at all and it didn't um
it doesn't it doesn't strike me as about
inclusion or
diversity or equity much no
no it's not much one irony after the
other yeah
so now um i had started seeing
actually in my pictures you can show
zach as well and i guess dad has some
too there were all these volunteers
um showing picture uh
all these volunteers uh picking up trash
um
because our
sky-high taxes in the city of portland
um
apparently can't cover trash cleanup
after riots we have to
we have to bring in volunteers and these
volunteers were to a person
you know seemed lovely and they were
doing they were doing work that needed
to be doing
that needed to be done and um why
why are we using volunteers not only why
are we using volunteers but there's
something about the way portland
cannot prevent a riot but it is right on
cleaning up and trying to minimize the
appearance
of the riot the day after and this has
been going on
you know for you know since since the
beginning of the
george floyd riots last year
and we could smell solvent some places
we were walking where they had already
cleaned up a bunch of the graffiti right
this morning
right they they have a mechanism for
cleaning the stuff up and the point is
what part of you doesn't understand that
it is your obligation
to prevent this and yes clean up that
which you cannot prevent
but you know doing whatever spending
whatever including the labor of people
who are not being paid to clean up
you know presumably portland's best
citizens volunteers who are willing
to make downtown nicer in such a
terrible circumstance
are paying the cost of portland's worst
citizens
who frankly have told us what they want
to do they want to burn it all down they
don't believe in
any of this stuff they don't believe
that there are rules that can work
they've told us they don't get it right
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to leave the cost
to you know the most benevolent among us
to
to deal with the vandals rather than you
know
support the police in doing good police
work
and arresting people who harm portland
and
its citizens i mean it's just so obvious
you might again this
should not be we should not be required
to say this
but supporting the police and their
ability to do good police work
can and i believe should include um
restricting some of what the police are
currently doing which they shouldn't be
doing and
actually getting mental health
professionals um to be able to respond
to actual mental health calls as opposed
to having police be first responders for
all manner of calls including ones for
which they are neither trained
um nor is it the best use of their time
so um
unfortunately that that proposal has
often been trotted out as a replacement
for police
and that's insane just as frankly
it's insane to have police doing all of
the work some of which would be better
done
um by by mental health counselors right
or you know i don't even i don't
i don't know this you know this is not
my purview but clearly
there are at least two and probably many
more sorts of work
that need to be done and at the moment
the police force is being forced to do
all of it and of course now it's being
forced to do all of it
on a shoestring budget with hemorrhaging
of the police force
because of course good police are
running away of course they
are yeah really they're in a no-win
situation
and you know uh i've talked to police
about
the fact that people are literally
calling for their heads
burning them in effigy etc and
you know i must say they
appear to be unaffected by this and just
treat it as oh yes that happens on the
other hand
you know what a terrible thing to have
this
job and to have good policing
declared impossible and all police
declared
guilty by a bunch of people who know
nothing right yeah that just
it's it's an appalling way to treat an
essential uh
function of society and um and you know
the the disaster here is just is too
predictable so it's not soon enough but
one thing we need
is a candidate for mayor who's not even
worse than
ted wheeler because um you know we
collectively voted ted wheeler back in
after a summer of demonstrably appalling
governance uh because the person who was
closest in the polls
was literally a member of antifa
remember i you know who knows but like
a supporter of antifa yeah yeah now the
problem though
is i agree we desperately need a mayor
who isn't insane and frankly i think
uh ted wheeler has behaved
very very stupidly but i don't think
he's an idiot he could get the message
and start behaving
reasonably he could but one way or the
other either
he wakes up to what's going on and
figures out what must be done
or he doesn't and he has to be replaced
by somebody else but
you wouldn't want the job right if you
have that job
of course police are running away of
course the good you know right
of the people who could do the job don't
want it yeah um and
you know my point is at some level this
is also on the citizens of portland
who are bending over backwards to see
reason where there is none right yes and
you know i wouldn't want the job of
mayor because i would worry
that doing exactly the right thing would
just be
punished right that doing the right
thing because it would be portrayed as
authoritarian
or fascist or whatever it would would be
portrayed as
would result in um you know uh
every good bit of governance going
thoroughly punished
yeah so following up on
you know like like i said the taxes are
very very high in portland and
um in a functional system uh that's okay
um we are not
usually in the position of wondering
where are all those tax dollars going
but right now we certainly are
yeah um especially when you've got
literally volunteers doing trash cleanup
after after riots um and then
this is something we were going to talk
about last week but we talked about
other things instead
meanwhile the schools in portland which
you know schools are always a big
a big piece of a city budget um are
working hard on things like changing
their names
and their mascots um and so many of you
will have heard this that
um wilson high school named for the
president um
has recently been named the ida b wells
high school
and you know as it turns out ida b wells
is a heroic and interesting and valuable
historic figure um
i think that any of these name changes
when they are coming
now um under threat basically are a
mistake
and um you know i also never saw any
argument for why wilson was
you know a horrible person except he
didn't live right now and abide by all
of the woke creed right
um but we see you know we even if you do
that you're not good enough right
um so um they the school changed their
name
back i can't remember maybe february of
this year something like that when
official
january and then they felt that they had
to change their mascot as well
and they actually put out to people in
the community
a number of possibilities and the
possibility that one
was the evergreens yeah you wanna
pick this up no no i just uh we didn't
talk about this last week
no okay um so all right the evergreens
i do another podcast in my head and i
think we did talk about it last week but
um but on this podcast we didn't and
um so yes the evergreens uh
won which caused uh you know a small
shutter in our family because you know
yeah i know that when i had been had i
had the opportunity to vote for a mascot
and i honestly don't remember what i
voted for but i saw evergreens and i was
like oh hell no come on let's not
i don't i don't need to be constantly
reminded of evergreens right right
right but um but it won but it won okay
and then
uh a member of the now ida b
wells community pointed out
that ida b wells was a uh famous
anti-lynching activist
and therefore somehow
evergreen trees can't be
mascots because
i don't know something instead of logic
too dumb for fiction too dumb for
fiction is what it is it is too dumb for
fiction if you wrote this into a book
a good editor would say sorry no not
plausible
that doesn't work the association with
trees
any trees with a a black woman who was
an activist in an era when lynching was
happening and therefore
of course she was anti-lynching i mean
like aren't we all
but also like of course she was you know
it
can we also not use wooden bookcases
like i i don't where does it stop
i mean it's just it's just too really
absurd um
it's it's too absurd and then on the
same that that happened
a week or so ago the evergreen mascot
kerfuffle and of course they've they've
caved they've said oh we're going back
to the drawing board we're going to
consider some other mascot choices
because it can't be evergreens
wait um and then yesterday we got
these things in the mail apparently
apparently we need to license our cats
we do we we can't do not we need to
license our cats
um carry them concealed
especially if we're gonna carry them
concealed um
yeah so there are fee options here so we
can um we could pay for one year or two
years or three years at a time for the
licensing of our cats
and um for which we will receive i did
go on the website and find out what
we'll receive for this
and you know it's not it's not insane
it's you know it's about animal control
and and
you know if we do license our cats maybe
they'll return them to us if they get
lost although i think that would require
that they wear tags and if they ever met
cats
cats slip their tags like anyway um
on the same day that portland governance
once again
fails to keep a freaking violent
mob from destroying a bunch of downtown
and then employs a citizen army of
volunteers to help do the cleanup
they're asking us for money to license
our cats yes our cats to license
our cats our cats right uh who are
anarchists so in some ways it would make
sense but they're libertarians
yeah you're probably right about that
you're right about that but um
but yeah there is there is i mean i have
to say it's very hard
not to um to juxtapose these two facts
especially
i mean let's let's draw the connection a
little tighter than
the effect of the failure to enforce the
law
and punish the guilty for destruction
downtown
it is of course closing businesses as
you saw there are shuttered businesses
across downtown and yes some of that is
coveted but a lot of that has to do with
you have to be crazy to start a business
especially in downtown portland at the
moment
right there are roving bands of maniacs
and the only way apparently not to get
vandalized is to
uh you know proclaim things in your
window that satisfy them or something
and that won't work either yeah long
term that's not going to work but
anyway the point is by
treating these claims the claims of the
writers
as sacred and therefore coddling the
behavior
that they engage in as they ostensibly
advance these aims we
are killing the tax base
of portland right the businesses of
portland are going to flee
and that means there will be less tax
money with which to do nice things for
the people of portland with which to
build out portland so it is a more
vibrant city with more jobs
that would be helpful to people and so
if you think that the result of
destroying businesses in portland is
going to be good for people who are
historically impr
oppressed you you don't understand how
things work
so um the idea of yes
we are going to nickel and dime the
citizens of portland we're going to
demand more and more tax money as we
behave in a way that is going to drive
businesses out which is going to lower
the salaries and eliminate the careers
of people who live here force them to
move to other cities
so you're going to be left with an
underemployed city
and then you're going to squeeze it for
taxes that's a that's a death spiral for
a city yeah
and yet somehow nobody in city
government can figure this out
so yes we will license those cats when
you start
enforcing the law in a way that is
colorblind and ideology blind
and species blind and all of those
things
you're looking at me that way again
i meant the first three of two of those
things yeah and not species blind i
don't i don't think we want uh
enforcement of law that is species blind
no although that may be on the list of
demands from the yahoo's downtown at
some point
yep yeah um all right are we
are we done with portland for today are
we done with portland we are not quite
done with portland but it will come back
as we discuss our next topic i have a
feeling okay um
okay really yeah the numbers
we're gonna talk about three and ninety
and thirteen and two point five billion
i'm not i'm i am i have girded my loins
for the 2.5 billion
okay i don't know where portland shows
up in here in these numbers uh
13. oh
okay yes yes i remember now um
so um just just briefly okay three comes
up this week these are just numbers
from the news this week uh the ceo of
pfizer
has said that it is likely that people
are going to need a third
shot a booster shot of the pfizer
covet vaccine a year after getting the
first two
and there um that there may just need to
be an annual
um an annual routine of shots and
apparently the j j
guy i don't know if it was the ceo or
not um said something similar
as well with regard to their shot um so
you know of course this raises the
question like maybe
maybe this is just going to be like the
flu shot um where the virus is evolving
out from under us as we know it to be
and so boosters are required to get a
closer fit to the actual virus the
people who are developing the vaccine
can get a closer fit to the actual virus
that is um maximally in circulation at
the time
but you know it does raise the question
for me it
raises so many questions but do any of
the vaccine manufacturers actually have
a good idea of like what a closer fit to
any of the
current variants would be or do we have
any way of knowing
what variants are actually going to be
maximally circulating so
let's separate two things traditional
booster shots are necessary not because
of the change of the virus but because
of the degradation of the immunological
memory you're right i used booster
i used booster incorrectly although the
pfizer ceo did as well
um that does not yeah breed confidence
yeah i was i was
i was using his language but you're
right anyway i don't want to nitpick i
just want to say there are two reasons
you know so the flu shot that you
supposedly should get every year
is about the fact that it's a different
it's a new vaccine
yes because it's a new flu right and
that seems like so that's what may be
happening here with kova well
both things are likely to happen here
with code okay
so um on the one hand we have the very
frightening prospect
that the way that these vaccines target
the spike protein is going to cause
these
escape mutants to dominate and that we
will be chasing
we're basically just signed up for an
arms race and that we are
learning of um the nature of that arms
race that this is you know i don't know
so why aren't both things always
happening though i mean
again we're gonna go back to virus
origins and you know maybe this is
evolving so rapidly
in such a unpredictable way precisely
because uh it did not it is not like any
other virus we've seen before
but you know why doesn't say um needing
to get a rabies booster every ten years
if your titers are low for instance
um not about both um
in you know increasing your titers and
also
um with new variants of rabies that has
evolved in those 10 years
um in the rabies case it's easy i think
because rabies is so very rare
that what you have is a virus that
doesn't have a large canvas on which to
paint and for which there is not
a lot of pressure for it to evolve since
such a tiny percentage of any population
has rabies the point is rabies
traditional rabies
always has naive animals um
to infect so it doesn't get an advantage
for change so potentially the more
common the pathogen the more difficult
um it it will be to make a vaccine that
is targeted and targeted for a while
and you know maybe even i actually have
no idea but you know i've been tracking
for decades like
hoping for the malaria vaccine like
really really hoping for it and yeah
it turned you know maybe an mrna vaccine
um
and i don't know um but uh
somehow that one is super elusive in a
way that other mosquito vector diseases
um like yellow fever have not been yep
um
so i think two things are true one
um there is a large landscape of
immunological understanding and then
there's a large landscape of what we
don't know
i mean i will not cite donald rumsfeld
in this case
but uh his wisdom is relevant here with
respect to what we do and don't know
it turns out there was some far more
ancient philosophical
uh thing that he was actually riffing on
when he talked about the known knowns
and the known unknowns and the unknown
knowns and the unknown unknowns
well the thing is i'm a little addicted
to the cringe when you
um when you invoke donald rumsfeld as a
a source of wisdom you know he's like
the
the evil yogi berra or something like
that but
but in any case um so we may or may not
be dealing with
both a booster situation here yeah where
your
your immunological memory decays over
time and therefore you need a booster to
remind your immune system hey this thing
is still out there
yep um and we are almost certainly
dealing with
this um case where we are putting
intense pressure on the uh
the spike protein by targeting it
very narrowly with a vaccine that
focuses only
on that and indeed only on the original
variant of the spike protein
which basically means that any way in
which the spike protein can change
that is electromagnetically dissimilar
from the original spike protein
gives it an advantage in hiding from the
immune system and so
voila there's your arms race yeah yep
there's your arms race
all right so um that's three now let's
actually skip to
90 before we're going to 13 because it's
more in keeping with three
um so 90 is the percent chance that if
you self-administer one of the now
widely available home cova tests in
england and you get a positive result
that that positive is false ninety
percent
false positive rate of these
self-administered tests that are um
now being widely used widely distributed
as if i think it was april 9th
and which the results of which are being
used to decide whether or not you have
to quarantine and thus
lose you know work school life
everything opportunities
so ah boy
this sounds really cocked up
this is british right i die is that
british yes
okay that doesn't sound british to me i
just guess
i deliberately used my most american
accent for it but
it's mighty cocked up if i'd said that
you would have spotted right away that
it was a british ism
okay so there's an article in the
guardian on this um
and i'll have you put it up in just a
second zach but
we discussed many episodes ago i did not
have time to go back and figure out
which episode or episodes it was in
the risks of false positives in testing
and you know no matter
and and when the first i think it was
when the first
i don't remember i don't remember what
exactly the context was but we were
talking about how
as disease prevalence falls the uh
proportion of people who are tested who
receive false positives goes up
and so you have a situation um
especially in the parts of england where
this is taking place
where background rates are understood to
be quite low where the false positives
are particularly high and it's having
therefore you know
in exactly the place where the disease
is the least risk
you have the highest proportion of
people who are suffering costs that they
should not be forced to suffer
especially after
13 months of this so let's just give
people the uh the logic that makes it
easy to deduce
okay in a case where you're testing for
a disease that is
if you were to test for smallpox right
a hundred percent of positives are false
right because there's no smallpox
anymore
so um as the disease prevalence falls
the percentage of those who get a
positive uh
that is false it goes up for this weird
reason so
um so anyway what does this do to us in
the case where
you've got a low prevalence of covid in
britain
and uh a test that is now being how
frequently do you say it's being
administered um well
here i'll read you two paragraphs from
this from this piece in one email
ben dyson an executive director of
strategy at the health department and
one of health secretary matt
hancock's advisors stressed the quote
fairly urgent need for decisions on the
point at which we stop
offering asymptomatic testing so this is
basically expected that the entire
population is doing this asymptomatic
testing reliably in order to
get back to normal which we all want
quote on the 9th of april the day
everyone in england was able to order
twice weekly
lateral flow device tests these are lfd
tests
dyson wrote as of today someone who gets
a positive lfd
result in say london has at best a 25
chance of it being a true positive
but if it is a self-reported test
potentially as low as 10 percent
on an optimistic assumption about
specificity or as low as
2 on a more pessimistic assumption so
that rate of false positives
is from 75 to 98
um on these tests that are being that
they want people to be doing all the
time
and you know of course you've got one
you one person who is now doing this
twice a week for many weeks
um is is not does not even have just
you know if they get a positive
they are increasing their chances of
getting any positive and their chances
of that positive being false
are 75 to 98 depending and because
they're having to take more and more
tests the chances of them getting a
positive
or higher right now there are a number
of things we want to know in order to
figure out whether a reasonable policy
could be rescued out of a test that's
this bad
right right so one thing you want to
know is does
one false positive predict other false
positives
in the same person right right if it was
true that any
given test could throw a false positive
but then if you took a second one
uh it would be likely i think the answer
to that
if that it would be likely to not give a
false positive i think that is like
the case because they're talking about
um it
sounds like they're talking about doing
that but of course then you've got
double the number of tests well no you
don't have to have on there
you you have you you have to follow up
with anyone who's got it you have to
follow up and you traumatize people who
oh my god i got a
positive covid test do i have covid um
so anyway
there's also the question on the good
side the reason that you might deploy a
test
this bad is that if the false negative
rate is low
then those with covid will be in the
sample of those who test positive even
though most of those people
are negative so you could if your point
is we have to stop kovid from spreading
and the point is within the small number
of people who get a positive test
most of them don't have covid but
everybody who has coveted is in that
sample too
then you could behaviorally shift things
around those yes
and it could function but you would want
to be very clear with the public
don't freak out when you get a positive
test take another one
assuming that a second one is not
predicted to give you another false
positive
yeah and the you know if the second one
is negative you don't have it which
would be true if the false negative rate
was low
so you could rescue a policy out of this
but
on its own that's just a shocking number
of false positives yeah it sure is
um yeah maybe that's it
um the next number we want to talk about
is
13 yes
uh should i start
yeah uh let me actually find um
i forgot to pull up
uh there is of course discussion
my computer is not working now um
now of uh court packing
right of uh the
biden administration here we go um
no oh okay never mind um
yeah this is not the one maybe it is the
one
okay yeah i guess you can show this um
so robbie george uh who was a friend of
ours extraordinary
uh man who is the um who was a professor
at princeton of law tweets
this week as long as people understand
that court packing is a performance not
a proposal will all be fine
parentheses performance masquerading
performances masquerading as proposals
or anything but unusual in american
politics and indeed in politics
generally
the important thing is to see them for
what they are
so i saw this yesterday and actually
he'd done one earlier which is what i
was trying to pull up but i
but i'm not finding it um and i breathed
a sigh of relief
and it's like oh boy you know if anyone
knows
it's it's it's professor george and um
i sure hope he's right and i made
contact with him to see
um to see on what basis he was making
that claim and we got on the phone with
him yesterday and
spoke with him for a while and um i
don't you know neither of us uh
robbie george is a constitutional
scholar and we are not
um but in in very brief and you will
um you will correct me as i make errors
and then we apologize for any errors
that remain
um the constitution only mentions the
supreme court
congress needs to create all the other
courts so the only court mentioned
by the constitution the supreme court
the other courts are implied their
existence
uh is implied it says and other courts
as may be necessary or something i think
that's right yep
uh the supreme court has explicit
jurisdiction in conflicts between states
and between foreign ministers
but does not have roving jurisdiction in
all things of the states
and the original number of supreme court
justices
uh was not specified by the constitution
congress had to decide that
and they could have chosen anything they
could have chosen one they could have
chosen 800 they could have chosen
anything they chose five
there was no building for the supreme
court at first they were um
they were itinerant they rode a circuit
around the country doing what they did
when in washington they met in the
congress but often they rode circuit
which meant they went out to the other
uh judicial circuits and made rulings
apparently in
pubs and saloons and yeah yeah yeah
um and and i i think um
in part because this work was um you
know was on horseback going out into the
countryside
that basically five pretty quickly
didn't seem like it was enough and so
um due to issues of what was invoked was
sort of issues of workload
that number went up to nine and actually
flux fluctuate i think
like nine ten nine eight um around there
and then kind of stuck at nine
um pretty early i can't remember
um
yeah some sometime in the 1800s but i'm
not sure exactly when
um i don't think we need to do
should you want to talk about all this
stuff about judicial review and dred
scott
no i don't i don't think we we need to
so um
basically then fast forward to um
fdr okay so fdr
um and his new deal era laws were being
repeatedly struck down so you know we
had
nine supreme court justices at this
point and his new deal his new deal era
laws were being repeatedly struck down
by the supreme court and this pleased
him not at all
um unlike today when um it's pretty
transparent
and uh a government will say actually we
just don't like the tenor of the court
and so we're going to add more justices
the uh explanation for um why
fdr felt that there were more justices
needed
um was that work is very demanding and
the justices are very old and so we're
going to make new spots on the court for
everyone over
70 and a half years old 70 and six
months who's on the court and that turns
out to have been knight as six of them
so with a you know just like that fdr
was suddenly gonna get 15 justices where
before they were nine he was going to
get to a point six of them and boy was
that going to change the tenor of the
courts there were
i think if there were like four uh
dedicated conservatives and three
dedicated liberals and there were two
um who um who
would go either way and in fact it was
um justice owen roberts who was one of
those two
who started to switch his votes and
again we're not going to get into
some of the details here such that fdr
did not end up
going through with his plan
um to to basically pack the court but
the fact is that court packing that
court packing proposal by fdr
was in many legal scholars views maybe
the second biggest black eye for him
that he did he did a tremendous amount
of of
of good i would argue for sure um and
then there were a couple things that he
did that were really
quite egregious and the top item on that
list was the
um decision um for the internment of the
japanese the japanese americans
on you know on which side there are a
number of people you wouldn't have
expected
uh to be uh and then you know
by by professor george's estimations and
apparently other legal scholars as well
this um this attempt to pack the court
was really the second
most egregious thing that fdr did
because
it would be the end of judicial
independence if any president can do
that
then you do not have an independent
judiciary and
that's just that's the end you know
that's that's the end of our system of
governance
at the end because it will create a uh a
arms race in which uh each new
administration adds members to the court
to change
its decision-making effectively it makes
it a a subordinate of the executive
branch and so that's the danger we're in
here this is why this is part of why
some of us are so alarmed to hear this
proposal you know it's not that this
wasn't floated
uh at the end of the trump
administration as um
you know something that as a proposal
during the election
right by biden but um to hear it
actually
uh offered as a policy shift is
jarring and i must say i also had the
reaction i was very troubled in hearing
that they would seek new seats on the
supreme court and i was very relieved to
hear
relieved and surprised to hear robbie
george
say that he he thought this was uh never
going to happen
yeah his i mean his position um was
basically
uh everyone in congress knows
this history that i just told you yeah
and um
there will be a lot of performative
stuff going on
and people will trade votes behind the
scenes in order to
be able to say that they did or they did
not vote for this thing
um but um
you know he's he's a conservative so i
think he said something like even the
democrats know
that this would be the end of judicial
independence and therefore
cannot have well the democrats know
and a few democrats in congress are too
smart to let it happen
that doesn't mean that there aren't
democrats who would do this
there certainly are but the point is you
need all the democrats
to support this proposal and there are
enough democrats who understand the
hazard of this and do not you know
both would prevent it because it's the
right thing to do
and also don't want responsibility for
destroying the independence
of the judiciary um and so they won't
and so
uh professor george's point was
the vote might end up being close
because to the extent that people know
it's going to fail they can get in and
signal for free
um but that it will it will fail and he
said he could be wrong
but that he doesn't but that this looks
like a proposal that is being offered
for virtually signaling uh value and not
as a serious proposal and that you can
tell
because in part the committee that has
been established to
look into this is both too large to
function he said we as academics would
recognize this i think he said it has 36
people on it
i remember being co-chair of a committee
to find a new provost was
which the president of the college not
george bridges put
17 people on and it's like you just
don't want us to succeed what is wrong
with you
right this one has 36 people and so so
dr george said
look it's too big they they made a
committee that can't work
um and what's more uh they put
conservatives on it and not only do they
put conservatives but they didn't put
brain-dead conservatives they put smart
conservatives on there
so anyway they've set it up to fail
which okay if that's true
it's still it's a despicable proposal
but um
we can breathe a sigh of relief that
it's not actually going to happen
yeah and um so let's see
so we're going to get caricatured as
right wingers who want a conservative
court
and um and you know we're citing a uh
conservative law professor
uh in order to support our contention
that this would be a bad idea
how do you deal with the caricature or
i'm in a tough spot here i have a
feeling you are too but that's why i
bring it up
i will speak for my myself
um i am concerned about the
number of important properties which
govern us
some of which are official governance
properties like the executive branch
and the congress um but others
unofficially govern us you know uh
silicon valley
for example um i'm concerned about the
degree
to which runaway left-wing thought
owns these important structures
and that it is the failure of anything
to credibly oppose
these wrong beliefs that is putting us
in such danger
so whereas i would not under ordinary
circumstances
prefer a conservative court i think i
would not
uh prefer a conservative court although
there's an argument that even if you're
a radical like me that you want a
restraining force
and it might be that the court is the
place for conservatism but at the moment
with this runaway uninvestigated uh
team blue left-leaning stuff
you need some force that can say no and
really the only one
left is the supreme court so at this
point
uh i you know there's nothing wrong with
talking to
a conservative robbie george is a great
guy and he he has a very deep
understanding of
uh the issues in play
and he differs with us somewhat on
values but it's not like i
you know don't respect his perspective
or feel any shame at all
in talking to him he's the person i
would go to first to understand
anything in this in this realm um but it
is also the case
that um the court packing proposal
is dangerous the idea that it is
a remedy is preposterous right
it is nakedly political and at this
moment if we have you know if there was
ever an argument
for a conservative court this is the
moment that we
need such a thing and you know i say
that with full understanding that there
are certain
uh questions that the court may rule on
in which
you know we might get decisions that are
uh
very troubling to those of us who are
to those of us on the left but
nonetheless that may be the price we
have to pay
to have any branch of government that is
capable of restraining the the
the out of control forces that have
taken control of
uh of all things governance yeah we we
have
we have lost in too many places a loyal
opposition
right and this is this harkens back also
to what i was
invoking about what's happened in
portland that in the last
election which was also a mayoral
election here in portland we actually
had to vote for the guy who helped
um create helped facilitate at that
point
what would have been five months of
protest that reliably became riots and
made
our beautiful downtown a disaster zone
we had to vote for him
because uh the other pers the person
running against him was farther to the
left
farther and not you know not this isn't
the left i recognize farther to the
anarchist
farther to the destroy everything burn
it all down all cops are bastards
and you know we it's hard to imagine
it's really it's impossible really to
imagine a republican candidate for mayor
in portland getting anywhere but
we need we we need two sides to this
to the degree that there are two
legitimate sides and of course there's
you know you can frame these sides and
across all sorts of axes
but we need for any given set of issues
there to be
a vibrant and lively set of people on
the other side who are allowed to speak
and who wield some power so they can
push back and we don't have that in
portland
and we largely don't have that in the
democratic party and we don't have that
among corporate ceos largely we don't
have that in silicon valley we don't
have that in hollywood we don't have
that in the media we don't have that in
academia
and so and this is not the left
that you and i grew up with this is not
a left that that
we stand by and are proud of and so you
know
it's therefore even more clear to us um
how
how much we need um you know opposing
forces
whether or not you agree with those
opposing forces because their existence
itself is what's necessary so i have a
a little rubric uh around this which of
course you do
um so there's you know there's a reason
i've shown on the podcast before my
political compass test which has me
really far over to the left and really
far over to the libertarian so lower
left hand
anti-authoritarian right and very far
left
there's a reason i land there right and
it's because of values and beliefs that
i actually do
hold but it does not mean that i think
the left is correct and it would be
better off if the right simply
disappeared
i know this not to be the case right the
point is you have a dynamic
tension between the instinct towards
progress to make things better
which if left unopposed always treads
into territory where it creates
unintended consequences
and it does harm uh and
the impulse to preserve what functions
which if
unopposed becomes stifling right becomes
stingy and stifling and it doesn't
accomplish lots of things that could be
accomplished so what you want
is a force pushing in the direction of
making things better
and a force holding its feet to the fire
and making sure it doesn't
propose dumb things that get out of
control right
it's the tension between those two
things that makes the system work
and my sense is anybody on either side
who thinks we'd be better off if the
other side disappeared
has already told us they don't
understand anything about governance and
they can be safely ignored
that's it right there that that deserves
to be
shattered from the rooftops anyone on
either side who thinks would be better
off that the other side disappeared
has told us already that they know
nothing about how things work and they
don't deserve to be listened to
it's really important and you can always
detect this anytime
any party whether it's the [ __ ] nazis
or the democrats who starts thinking or
dreaming about one party rule and what
it's going to do now that it's finally
decisively defeated the opposition right
that
is a dangerous force and it has to be
opposed so
um no shame whatsoever in talking to
honorable conservatives
and the interesting thing is you will
find oh universally i don't
anyone who says that you're a problem
for talking to people i'm not
i don't i'm not interested in responding
to that that was not the caricature that
i was talking about it was the
caricature of
you know you're concerned about the
expansion of the supreme court well
then you must love all of the all of the
uh people who've recently been put on it
well we're actually haven't even spoken
to that at all yeah
yeah um yeah so in any case
people on both sides who get it
recognize the importance of
the tension and i would just say the
final capstone on this
is uh this is me speaking in riddles i
guess but
um i i'm a liberal who wants to live in
a society
so good that i get to be a conservative
and
the point of the point about this is if
you're actually fighting for a kind of
progress that's achievable
then having attained that progress you
don't want to keep going in the
direction of progress for its own
sake so yeah now i mean just think
many people on the left think they're
environmentalists and another word for
environmentalist is a conservationist
and conservationists and conservatives
share that root of wanting to conserve
something that exists
and uh if if you if you actually don't
think you can ever attain what you're
trying to do
then you need to stop breaking stuff in
our presence and
and let us create good things and if you
really think uh that the good things
that exist are not worth conserving
then what universe are we in
that doesn't make any sense it's
incoherent yeah we're in a universe of
children throwing a tantrum because
they're not happy and they don't know
why
right and you know again i think we have
to be
fair at some level part of the reason
that we have
so many people eager to burn it all down
people who do not understand what would
happen
if we burned it all down is because
society has
failed to provide meaningful
opportunities for large numbers of
people it's
drugged them when you know the real
problem was that we under-invested
in you know schooling and other such
things
and failed to understand what children
are and what development is
right and we've allowed uh markets to
deliver
uh toxic toys to all of
us that have deranged people who could
otherwise
have you know learned to think clearly
um so anyway it's not like there isn't
some problem that these
kids throwing a tantrum in the street
and burning down businesses with no
understanding of what world they are
inviting
you know something created that force
and it didn't start with these people
but you do
have to discipline people who have
decided to uh
to destroy that which they could not
have built
yeah that's right all right we're done
with 13. oh did you want to show a
picture of it
yeah as long as it yeah let's go to nine
yeah uh
let's go well it was 13 but it's gonna
be nine
um so uh yeah zach will you show the
ninth circuit
yeah so in our walk around downtown
portland this morning uh the three of us
brett sac and me uh we ran across the
ninth circuit court
um here in portland yeah i mean it's
actually
one block from the apple store
on pioneer square uh here you go so
yeah this is not my favorite picture
from the lot but nonetheless
here we have the door to the ninth
circuit
um and it is of course boarded up
because in portland you wouldn't want to
have glass on the ground floor
because you know that could uh invite
rioting
beautiful city yeah so anyway the irony
of this of course
is that those who are focused on
oppression should be standing around
the ninth circuit shoulder to shoulder
protecting it
against violence because courts are
absolutely the best tool we've got and
it's not to say
that courts haven't made serious errors
right you know in talking to robbie
george yesterday
you know we talked about dred scott for
example right um courts make errors
but on balance you know it's like seat
belts right do seat belts kill a few
people they do people
you know go into the water and they
can't escape their car but in general
when you click the seat belt you just
made yourself way
safer because the net effect of seat
belts is so positive
well the net effect of courts on the you
know rights and opportunities of the
oppressed is
wildly positive and yet here you have
you know hoodlums attacking the ninth
circuit
and the apple store and basically
anything that's standing they wish to
reduce to rubble
and it tells you they don't understand
anything about what's good for the
people they claim to be
advocating for yeah
all right uh 2.5 billion is our next
number is our final number before we
talk a little bit about lizards and a
little bit about coyotes
um
do you want to take a guess or you
you're just you're synesthetically
terrified at the moment
um by 2.5 billion
2.5 billion is the number of
people on earth who understand
that helium and hydrogen have
mass even though they will rise
rather than fall towards the earth you
think 2.5 bill how many people do we
have about seven and a half billion
eight uh yeah seven and a half days you
think a third of the earth's population
knows that helium and hydrogen have mass
um i think that's high i think you're
high
well i'm not but uh no you're right i'm
sorry it's probably high
okay um no in fact the number 2.5
billion
um is the is the number of people who
know that
insects are animals um
yeah i wish that number was higher i
hope it's that high
sure yeah that still seems high probably
really yeah
i'm afraid so no i think it seems just
about right
okay
so no because really it's just got to be
the number of
the educated and the uneducated both of
which will grasp that these have to be
animals and it's the sort of educated
who will
miss it right i don't i don't know
i i don't know
um so this week they showed up a bunch
of places and i think frankly a lot of
them
corrected it um and the only
headline that i recovered uh was from
cnn which proclaimed
how many t-rex were there billions it
turns out
and there are all these headlines this
week that were like 2.5 billion
tyrannosaurus rex has once roamed the
earth
and um and you know i looked at that
first one like
what what what are they talking about
and um you know now if it had been
if it had been uh stegosauruses
you wouldn't have had this reaction
right of course i would have
you would have stegosauruses yeah
yes i hope i'm right about what a
stegosaurus is stegosaurus is a bigger
before
yeah yeah okay but 2.5 billion is a lot
of animals so i mean
precisely because it's sort of 2.5
billion is this number that's close
enough
to the number of humans on earth that
it's a number that although it's
actually
pretty hard to grasp for just about
everyone because it's kind of close
you know it's it's about a third of the
number of humans on earth right now
it's a number that most people can sort
of get a sense of like
or a third as many t-rexes on earth as
there are people
that seems improbable um so the actual
research apps here we go zach you just
show this briefly
absolute abundance and preservation rate
of tyrannosaurus rex published by
marshall at all
in this week's science estimating
dinosaur abundance here we have from the
abstract
we estimate that its abundance at any
one time was about 20
000 individuals that makes sense yes
that it persisted for about 127
000 generations multiplying which is a
lot
and it's a lot it's actually it's about
2.5 million years
and that the total number of t-rex that
ever lived
was there for about 2.5 billion
individuals
and then they go into what the fossil
recovery rate is estimated to be and
such
um okay that makes some sense
so and you know pretty much restricted
to north america 20 000 t-rex's at a
time in north america is pretty big
yeah actually that's a sizable
population um
but i i couldn't understand that like
that's plausible
right like how many how many bears do
you think there are north america right
now
i actually have no idea i just thought
of that question i i don't know but like
probably far fewer than 20 000 at this
point but
you know we're how many there's north
america
yeah you think there's more than that
well a lot more than that really yeah
boy am i going to get myself in trouble
but yeah there's got to be a lot more
a lot more than that i mean if we're
including you know far reaches of
alaska and canada i i still include
canada and north america i'm willing so
do i
i'm very traditional i mean i'm a
liberal in many regards but i'm
conservative with respect
regarding canada as a geographic
conservative as part of
that's part of north america now i'm
very progressive in regards we've lived
places where we can almost see to canada
yes
you just stepped on the joke where i
pissed off the entire tiny population of
canada by claiming that it was really
the 51st state but
oh i'm sorry i i do i do want you to
piss off the entire population of canada
they're nice about it even one pistol so
nice unduly nice
um so anyway this you know there wasn't
an
actual innumeracy going on here but
these headlines and again unfortunately
i think that so many people were like
what are you guys doing what are you
talking about that they corrected them
because they no one actually i think
reported wrongly about the actual
research
which is cool and it's lots of estimates
you know maybe the estimates are wrong
and they actually i think say i don't
remember now in the paper
like maybe off by an it might be an
order or
two magnitude in either direction maybe
it's just an order
of magnitude in either direction um
which would mean you know 250 million to
um 25 billion
um t-rex's but
the screaming headlines clearly made it
seem
like some scientists had just declared
that
a third as many humans as currently here
on earth
once roamed the earth at the same time
t-rex's and
that's insane it's insane but i do want
to point out
less insane if these had been
herbivores not gigantic herbivores well
i should look up how big a stegosaurus
gigantic organic okay i was looking for
a i was looking
uh what did they rename the uh
i can't i don't know neither of those
rivers yeah not not a dinosaur geek uh
i like birds but um
[Laughter]
we must have been going for a while now
right but but in any case
um you know how many cows are there in
north america well they've had our help
right but my point is there's also a
landscape out there you know there were
a lot of bison
i don't think there were 2.5 billion
bicycles no there weren't well
there aren't you know there are 300
million americans so
you know that's just correct for first
scale
but my point is a large number is
plausible if you're talking about a
moderate or small-sized herbivore the
idea that your top
carnivore could possibly attain such a
number is insane yes so that that is
also true but this number is so out of
scale
yes that like i didn't i didn't even get
there i didn't even get to being like
but it's a top carnivore it's like that
number
simply makes no sense right no and you
you reported the number to me uh with a
straight face
to see if i would you know if i was
paying attention
you know it was like a half a second of
like
what what what number did you just say
um but
that was partially predicated on the
fact that you know not only a carnivore
but a huge one yeah right the biggest
and so little tiny arms
[Laughter]
um but but anyway yeah it's it's amazing
but you know it harkens back to what we
described
was that last week when we talked about
the um
absurd rt uh headline about how the
amazon was actually contributing to
global warming it was by dying
you know essentially a longer time ago
than that but yes
but anyway it's that sort of thing where
it's like you know somebody in the
newsroom just
has the most tenuous grasp on science
and you know puts two and two together
and gets something in the neighborhood
of
seven and uh you know and then
only the math geeks will care about this
right but we don't like those people
anyway
what would it take to just get basic
quality control on scientific claims
in mainstream publication just basic
quality control
well apparently more than we're willing
to give could we start a service like
run it by a scientist
oh no that's not good enough run it by a
scientist who doesn't suck
right we could just collect some
scientists who don't suck you could
buy our time by the hour to just check
over a story
i'm not like you you are going to get
requests oh no yes
so you got to get yourself a project
manager because i'm not project managing
this one right here
someone want to create that app run it
by a scientist who doesn't suck
run up i said run it what would be the
acronym on that
so you you want an app run it by a
scientist
who doesn't suck um
yeah it doesn't it doesn't make a good
acronym no all right it means
it's smith it needs work yeah yeah so
you and uh
all the people who approach you about
this um can work what i need is an app
run it by a marketing person who doesn't
suck and they could come up with
something better
it's really not just the name this is
going to be the problem
[Laughter]
well okay um so
like we had a picture and i don't know
where the picture is now last week in
our q a
so usually we don't bring stuff from our
q a into the main part of the podcast
because people who are just listening
don't have access to that
uh you always do on youtube of course uh
we were asked about a lizard that
someone found while gardening outside of
seattle
um i have in my notes here is the animal
in question well i don't have the
picture
so all i have is i have a book
um i can't show the book though because
it's going to reveal
that this lizard is not a lizard at all
this lizard
is ambistema macrodactylum long toad
salamander
um terrible um
macrodactylum meaning long toad
um ambistuma uh it's the type genus of
the family ambisa mataday
um and it's a salamander it's not a
lizard
what's the difference huh so wow some
our tech is just freaking out today
isn't it
um i thought i actually
um and that keeps happening um
i could have shown any number of trees
for this but um here is a tree actually
that i created for inclusion in our book
so this
tree some version of it is going to be
in our book
um in the chapter in which we just go
through the deep history of
the lineage that humans have belonged to
and so we have
more or less reading left to right on
this tree
of tetrapods um time
more or less and then the the vertical
direction what would be a vertical axis
of this or an x y coordinate system is
meaningless
and so what you have here if you trace
um for instance here
um from the root of the tree up to
here at the top it happens to be the top
it could be anywhere
uh we have amphibians a salamander is a
type of amphibian um
and it's a totally different line up
here to get to
the lizards and lizards is not referring
to
lizards other lizards like amphibians
but other snakes and other lizards
and so this this is not the place to
give a systematics
lecture but point is amphibians
of which salamanders are a portion
are sort of a basal tetrapod group they
don't have
an ability to be totally free from the
water because they have an egg that
desiccates when they get away from water
and we had this um amazing innovation
called the amniotic egg
and all the reptiles and their
descendants which includes birds and
includes mammals in a separate lineage
of reptile descendants
are amniotes and we can be completely
free of the water and lizards are one of
those
one of those groups but many salamanders
look like
lizards and vice versa and there are
certainly diagnostic ways that you can
tell the difference but
um at some level this used to be an
answer
the very first field season that we
spent in graduate school we were in
costa rica
with john vandermeer who was our
professor and we had four or five other
grad students with us and he basically
created a
summer-long um tropical biology and um
and kind of land use course um and
you know he'd be walking around showing
us like that's welfia and that's
socratea and
she he loved the palms like oh my god
there's so many poems how do we tell the
difference and he he started to say
things like
the difference between that's gestalt
gestalt became the answer that he would
give to us as to how to tell the
difference between class organisms
sometimes be like
oh man you know that's not helpful
because we don't have the gestalt yet we
don't have the sense yet of what it is
that you are honing in on
and he's an excellent scientist he knew
that there are actually characters
that describe the history that revealed
that is revealed to be different
between these two different clades um
and
um he wasn't fully conscious of what he
was discerning but there are differences
between them well i think he was
always conscious of the actual
characteristics but
in general you don't need them and so
there were
time i think he was just you know i like
john quite a bit and
uh i appreciate his frustration over
certain things and so at some level what
he was saying was
figure it out that's one of these that's
one of those
they're different now you figure out
what the difference is so you can
reliably recognize them
and you know it is something you just
have to do and so it is you know gestalt
is basically like
uh you know once you get the trick
you'll you'll be able to spot the
difference even if you can't
or don't want to specify it but yeah
so one of the one of the easy
differences
between that you can you can tell a
salamander apart from a lizard
is that lizards have scales and some of
them are very smooth if you're looking
at a skink those
the scales are going to be very smooth
they're not going to be keeled they're
not kind of little ridges down them like
for instance rattlesnakes do
but they are scales if you if you look
at them close you find their scales and
salamanders have no scales and their
skin tends to be a little tackier
and often wet as well i actually think
it's very tasteful
yeah from all over your salamander
looking
speaking of salamander licking i did
want to point out that
um although salamanders and lizards are
distinct and recognizably so that we
have run into in our history one place
where the two were
conflated and it got recorded in an
official name
you remember is it aim for glasses no
it's something for glasses no no
no no not a latin name official place
name
place name yeah i mean like a common
name or a blizzard lake
remember lizard lake bc on uh on
vancouver island yeah yeah
so lizard lake is a lake with an
impressive population
of uh tariqa granulosa i think which is
the rough skin newt pound for pound
probably the most toxic animal on earth
all nuts are salamanders not all
salamanders or nuts correct
i know you know that that uh yeah uh so
anyway this lake it is an actual lake
um has because lake is a misnomer a huge
population
of these uh i don't know if this
population is always aquatic so
so tariqa tends to go on land sometimes
and then it breeds in the water they
migrate on land
they do they're like breeding migrations
on land but some populations
uh i think some populations only the
males are permanently aquatic anyway
there's some flexibility around it but
in this lake
uh you can stand on the side and look in
and in certain places you can see 10
20 uh individuals swimming around
they're very cool because they're toxic
they're
completely unafraid and so you can
interact with these newts
uh easily catch them don't lick them you
know licking them is not good
eating them is definitely not a good
idea yeah um
but anyway the same toxin as puffer fish
have
yes detroiter toxins
um so anyway the the uh the lake is
called lizard lake for no good reason
that's right um
and uh yeah well there you have it all
right um
i would gladly just go on and on about
lizards but i'm not going to
um we wanted to say a little bit about
coyotes
following up on last week um
so do you have video to show i do have
some video to show
and um maybe yeah
you want so you want to set it up sure
sure
um you last week brett um we're talking
about the game cameras that you've set
up all around our property and our
problem with these three coyotes
um that we've been seeing and how our
cats are going crazy because we've kept
them locked inside because these coyotes
are hunting our cats and everyone else's
cats as well
and one of them you saw on the game
cameras we saw in the game cameras that
you set up has
as one eye one either pupils blown out
you know we don't we haven't seen it
we now know more than we did but we
showed last time an animal
and only one of its eyes reflected which
is very unusual and you can see this
both
on the camera with the infrared and i
also saw it in my headlamp when i
look out and i look for eyes only one
eye reflected back which is
unique in my experience actually yep and
and almost certainly
um enough to diagnose like that's that
individual
like the chances that you know another
coyote in our area is missing their
right eyes
is very unusual um and you know again i
don't know if it's a hole in the head or
or
we didn't at that point no no anyway
yeah right um so what was it it would
have been like
mon maybe the very day after the podcast
last week sunday or maybe monday
um the weather was turning gorgeous here
and i was out with maddie our labrador
um out we we live on the edge of this
ravine that's this sort of
green space that goes down into creeks
that flows into a giant giant park
um about a mile away which is part of
why we have this coyote problem
um and i'm walking down down down
and maddie starts to freak out and um
she gets right up close to a tree
uh and i'm trying to get her to shut up
because um i don't know why she's
barking and
um and i come around this tree
and again we're on a very steep slope
and she's up against this big hole in
the base of the tree
and out of this tree is poking a snout
in a paw
so she has found a den and
and this snout in the paw are are
grabbing out at her you know
open-mouthed and
like oh oh crap our dog just found the
coyote den
um so i managed to get her away and pull
her up slope and get her inside and
and get you and we go right back down
and just as we get back down there
we see her as it turns out the one-eyed
coyote
leap out of this thing and and go away
and um then i i'll say one more thing
and i'll let you pick up the story
i um looked in the den and
found two kits so there's two two babies
in there
um just downhill of our house um that
um that mama coyote wanted to turn our
cats into more coyote
so anyway we uh quick as we could set up
some cameras
on the den and we caught a very
interesting
behavior so as i was setting up the
cameras heather heather was
uh standing just up slope with me and
the
coyote mother the one-eyed coyote
was essentially circling us and it would
go across the ravine and
howl it would go up above us and stand
on a log and howl this is middle of the
day she's howling
middle of the day um she gets someone
from a nearby house to start yelling
shut up
yeah like not going to work with a
coyote right
but anyway so she was very uh disturbed
by us and i
was pretty sure i knew what was gonna
happen which was she was gonna have to
move the kids
which so anyway i set up cameras and uh
why don't we show what we caught here
see you can see her
entering on the far right she's got a
path that she has worn
and the den is smack dab in the center
that iv
covered trees the ivy is an invasive
iv which we've been uh removing i
haven't wrapped it from this den because
i don't want to disturb it but
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
show the edited one
i edit so we set up this yeah we set up
the gopro
uh do you have her howling on this one
did you edit it down
okay did they hear it just now okay so
you can see her
approaching yeah so for those just
listening we've got her coming up the
path
well down and now up it's a very steep
path
only big enough for a coyote i tried to
navigate it okay now
you see her she's looking around she's
very concerned
and
still concerned standing at the front of
the dens presumably
it smells like us by now yep um
so she goes in
now what you just heard was her picking
up
one of her kits it starts to scream and
she
gently takes it in her mouth and leaps
out and runs away
out of frame now we only we only caught
the one
uh in video on the gopro
we have that just a fragment of the
removal of the other kit
on one of the game cameras yeah i don't
have it here
the game camera triggered late
i don't know you have another video i
don't know what that would be
jeez yeah i guess
yeah it's the same it's going to be the
same thing um so anyway but we have now
days
after we we have photographic and video
evidence of her removing both of the
kits
and then a visits by her and by at least
one other individual late that night and
on several successive nights as well to
the den
and in fact in one he goes in
so we don't know what the relationship
is between these animals now
this animal with the one eye has been
traveling around with two other animals
who look very similar to me
and i wondered before we knew about the
den
whether this was her you know a previous
brood whether these were two animals
that she was traveling with because
there are a lot of coyotes around here
and we hear them howling at night you
know there might be ten animals that we
hear
but these three travel together they get
along very very well and it seems like
they're probably
familial uh relations
and it is unclear from the game camera
whether or not the visit during the
night at the den that is now abandoned
is one of those two animals or whether
it's another animal and whether or not
i don't know i think it is unlikely but
it is possible
that those kits are actually the
one-eyed
mother uh by the way you can tell that
this is the same animal
because she also has a conspicuous black
patch on her back
um so anyway it makes it uh quite clear
that it's one
one animal but it could be her mate
which i think is unlikely based on the
way coyotes
usually bond um or it could be
one of the previous brood if that's
indeed who she is hunting with on a
nightly basis but
it's all very interesting yeah it is um
and just to pick up on um something else
that came up i think in the q a last
time
uh it was recommended uh that we get
wolf urine
and distribute it around to um
to deal with the coyotes and uh we
ordered some right up
but it just came late last night so we
have not yet had time so we do not yet
know
if or how that will work yes and
you know if the coyotes so we are still
getting evidence of coyotes each night
even though the den is now
abandoned um but if the coyote problem
clears up and we're left with all this
wolf urine we'll have to find other
things to do with it
i don't know if it's good as a drink
mixer or
sorry apparently we have not smelled it
we haven't opened it yet but
apparently it is quite putrid um yeah
i'm not
i'm not looking forward to using this
because who knows how it will disturb
the ecology you know it's going to drive
our own animals
nuts the sudden evidence of wolves
but it is also going to change the
ecology of
of the place which we're hesitant to do
because we're so interested in what's
going on out there right well uh it is
less likely to perturb the birds much
they are not primarily navigating via
smell
i think unless you have a particular
thumbnail that you've already decided on
that you want to show here
um we have reached the end
of this rather scatter shot chaotic
scatter shot chaotic but no trombones at
all
yeah not a one but not a single yeah
we'll use one of the uh one of the shots
from downtown
as the as the thumbnail all right so um
announcements please subscribe like
um if you're listening on the audio
write a review
um i think i think if you write a
comment on youtube that also affects the
algorithm
um we uh for those of you just listening
we'll be back next week
same time same place for those of you
watching if you feel like it join us in
15 minutes for a live q a answering
questions you opposed during
uh this hour in super chat and next hour
uh once again right now
the 48 hour period for answering asking
questions for a private
two-hour q a that we do monthly at my
patreon
is open so you can um go there to
heather heing's patreon
um brett also has patreon conversations
every month
at his um questions can go to
darkhorse.moderatorgmail.com
and let's see we've got
we haven't updated in a while we've got
some cool stuff available
at store.darkhorsepodcast.org and
the clips channel is continuing to put
out clips
at a remarkable rate and if there's
anything that you particularly want
clipped
please consider emailing again that
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com and subscribe to it like it
and spread that stuff around
absolutely and in the meantime be good
to the people you love
and eat good food and get outside or
else
i mean yeah get outside
sorry